all right so it seems a lot of you liked
my video on Mortal Kombat annihilation I
thank you for that is we're gonna switch
tracks we'll kind of kind of switch
tracks it's bad yet good its nineties
cheese so let's talk about it this is it
my if I can name a guilty pleasure movie
of 90s action cheese this is it
[Music]
street fighters the movie this is one of
those movies it's worth a thesis you
know I could talk about this movie
forever but this is it this is one of my
favorite guilty pleasure movies I just
watched it recently and it is indeed a
guilty pleasure movie not necessarily
gonna nitpick but just gonna pick a few
things to illustrate why I feel about
Street Fighter the movie how I feel so
Street Fighter the movie is another one
of those movies that I've talked about
in my Mortal Kombat annihilation review
but one of those video game adaptation
movies where they were like well we're
not gonna necessarily adapt to the video
game we're just gonna make another movie
throw some videogame characters in it
hopefully we have something that kind of
resembles the video game but not really
because here's the plot of Street
Fighter the movie a power-mad dictators
taken hostages he wants 20 billion
dollars or he's gonna kill the hostages
so the a end which is this movie's
version of the UN led by a colonel and a
couple of hustlers that he gets to work
with them they're gonna go in there and
hopefully save the hostages street
fighter yeah if someone told me the
filmmakers of this movie didn't play the
game I'd believe it looks like they were
like Oh Street Fighter doesn't have a
story which if they played Street
Fighter they'd know there is a story but
other than the plot you see that in the
characters dial is a military guy fair
enough he's a colonel in here they
promoted him for the movie I guess a job
you totally nailed Balrogs widow's peak
also he's Chili's cameraman makes sense
Canon Rio or a couple of hustlers
there's that Ryu moral fiber we all know
here's my favorite
Dhalsim is a doctor who creates Blanca
Blanca is going to be a super soldier
for bison be a captain shadaloo super
soldier thing they got going on also
Blanca was a guy named Carlos Blanca who
is also Kyle's friend Charlie still I
profess and I make the argument better
than Legend of chun-li this guy walks
through the raindrops it just is but hey
at least I got all the wind poses down
there's that the movie is just it's
littered with cheese but it owns its
cheese I mean yeah in a world Burt if
you wanted to nitpick the [ __ ] out of
this plot you could totally do that
whether it be that scene where guns or
toys I guess and what were they gonna
did they think they were real the movies
executed like oh they think these guns
are real guns they turned out to be toys
what were they gonna just splatter house
these guys right then and there with
guns with barrels that are that big
around like those rounds they had to
have thought they were grenade rounds
explosive
of some sort what they were just gonna
stand that close and annihilate these
guys is that as dumb as guile just
laying there in the morgue waiting for
chun-li to come find him oh yeah that's
stupid the movie is funnier than you
would think a street fighter movie would
be but it just feels like it's it's at
home in its place in the mid-90s it's
not that it all mixes well all the time
considering at some point in the script
reads someone was like okay and then ken
and Ryu walk in and a Honda and Balrog
capture them because they think they're
bad guys but ken and Ryu were actually
good guys and then Ken when he's getting
jokes says we're on the same side and
they think he says we can lead you
outside and that's why they let him go I
mean let's not try but the sense of
having fun with itself is something that
coming is coming straight off of Mortal
Kombat annihilation Street Fighter
watched them pretty much back to back
within a couple days Street Fighter has
more fun with itself then Mortal Kombat
annihilation I feel dead it was good the
feeling of Nile ation was like look
we're annihilation here you know the
realms are under attack earth realm is
falling there's no time to have fun with
that come on we're gonna take this
seriously also any of the jokes in that
movie we're just they were just
delivered in a way that fell flat I've
seen better
don't sweat I've seen worse too
Street Fighter has some whimsical fun
with itself and the one spearheading
that is raúl juliá as bison that was
casting was like I couldn't have called
that wouldn't have called raúl juliá as
bison but that timing he has in his
delivery that you see in the Addams
Family movies this weird comparison yeah
the talent scene is Gomez Addams you see
his and bison
weird it's a weird phrase but it's what
I mean because you do see it raúl juliá
he's a good actor he's an accomplished
actor dude is a thespian it's like he
read the script and he was like I know
what kind of movie this is and I know
what kind of villain I'm playing so I'm
gonna own it and he totally does is you
over the top absolutely but always
within the parameters of what the movie
is
oh but if you do want to see a more
serious take on m.bison we have it in
the legend of true and late it is not as
good just compare the energy between the
two Bisons 17 years four months and six
days you shall be killed bring the
package to Bangkok safely there is no
room for error until the very planet is
in the loving grip by sonica now I
understand they're going for two very
different things very different vibes
but the lesson here is just don't be
boring and Rolla Julius bison is
anything but that in fact the shadow he
casts is so big and so vast
I didn't even talked about Van Damme and
I don't feel the need to talk about
VanDam VanDam in this movies Van Damme
and for the entire movie he's entirely
enrolled Julius shada he's the perfect
cheesy 90s action movie villain he's
fantastic also I feel like anybody who's
anybody who talks about this movie they
talk about that line you know the line
the greatest burn response ever been
shewn Lee spills her heart bison he's
mixing a drink well she's talking about
this moment when she was a child that he
came into her town and killed her father
and his response is I'm sorry I don't
remember any of it and when she says you
don't remember he goes for you that day
bison graced your village was the most
important day of your life but for me it
was Tuesday it's amazing it's there
might have been the thing that made me
go oh this well ok yeah this is this is
fun oh [ __ ] I'm putting this video up on
Monday should have made it Tuesday I'm
going for a Monday Wednesday Friday
uploads schedule while all of this is
going on whether it be that and
admittedly that one scene where chun-li
and her crew they have the explosives on
the truck and they're rolling it into
that one camp where bison and Sagat are
hanging out and it's on a TV and Zangief
goes
change the channel no it's so stupid but
it works for this is ridiculous I said
actually has a couple of good burns in
this movie like when he addresses the
god I guess you didn't see that did you
some stuff does make me roll my eyes I
mean some stuff go on the barrel lid the
streetfighter arcade stick on Bisons
floating desk and in the end that's that
street fighter for me oh I wish they'd
made a live-action Street Fighter movie
that was like Street Fighter yeah but it
feels more like street fighter than
Legend of chun-li does it's a bad movie
that has a cheesy and daring quality to
it I do think a large part of it if not
possibly the sole part of its because
raúl juliá is and bison if he wasn't an
bison if we just got someone else this
movie would not be as memorable or fun
in its own way as it is Rallo Julia is M
bison is a classic case of one actor in
one performance that makes a movie
watchable cheesy bad fun whatever you
want to call it it's all on him he's the
one thing in this movie making it work
at all I do think Brian Thompson is Shao
Kahn and Mortal Kombat annihilation
tried to pull something like this off he
tried to be that over-the-top villain
like m.bison which does show how much
talent one has to have to pull that off
in a way that's still in the confines of
the movie not stepping out of it you're
not ruining the movie you're actually
elevating it and enhancing it that's
tough and raúl juliá did that in this
movie this is actually the movie of the
ratings sake the namesake of the rating
when I came up with the rating a good
time if you're drunk I gotta believe I
thought of Street Fighter the movie
enjoying its cheesiness with some drinks
along the way because Street Fighter the
movie is a good time if you're drunk
let's be honest kyle has an epic speech
[Music]
[Music]
all right so Street Fighter the movie
have you seen it what did you think
about it do you hate it do you love it
is that a guilty pleasure movie is it
just a guilty movie that's guilty of not
being good however you see it whatever
it is whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]